the bench players countess Gordon Brown  39 of the 58 points from the big three  and now it is clearly one of six teams  off major that's a good job here's Chris  militant nice doubter doubter the one  against the Grange 45 the Bucks  outscored Detroit by 45 points  okay right - my father bucks [ __ ] gosh  [Applause]  Lopez fans Yanis he sees a wall seven  beds down  yes  boys while in what auntie Yama sedan in  the fish back to tending gonna back down  for then Robertson and he'll six five  against Justin  [Music]  and I am 58 French don't break play yeah  and let so just kind of flooding the  passing lane active hands and they were  down is that they've been knocked out  eight rebounds two assists nine of 15  from the field he hit a three and his  two of four at the free-throw line  nanus has short 11 of the 21 in the  western half of the ball court